à l'initiative de volody mirzelenski les
présidents ukrainiens et chinois ont
échangé ce mercredi pendant près d'une
heure au téléphone une première depuis
le début de l'invasion russe de février
dernier
j'ai parlé avec le dirigeant de la Chine
aujourd'hui ce fut une conversation
longue et assez rationnelle on dit
généralement que de telles conversations
ouvrent des opportunités il y a
maintenant une opportunité de donner un
nouvel élan en relation entre l'Ukraine
et la Chine il existe une opportunité
d'utiliser l'influence politique de la
Chine pour restaurer la force des
principes et des règles sur lesquelles
la paix devrait être fondée
alliés de Moscou Pékin cherche à jouer
les médiateurs dans le conflit fin
février les autorités chinoises avaient
déjà proposé un plan de paix en 12
points parmi ces propositions la levée
des sanctions économiques le respect de
l'intégrité territoriale des
belligérants ou encore la mise en place
de corridor humanitaires la lumière
Poutine avait alors salué l'initiative
de shiginking le projet était resté
lettres morte la Chine tente de relancer
l'idée de négociation de paix et prévoit
d'envoyer des émissaires sur le terrain
enfin la Chine envers un Représentant
spécial pour les affaires eurasiennes en
Ukraine et dans d'autres pays la fin
d'établir une communication approfondie
avec toutes les parties d'un règlement
politique de la crise si Pékin tente de
jouer les juges de paix la diplomatie
chinoise n'a jamais officiellement
condamné l'invasion russe après l'appel
entre Shein ping et volodi mirzelenski
Moscou a réagi en reprochant à Kiev
d’être reposé au dialogue et à une
solution politique au